what do you think about the advice write
the script or make the movie you want to
watch
look I mean I think uh
I wrote the books I wanted to exist when
I was younger like it's I think there is
something important to
um be able to uh Express what it is
you're trying to say I think that's
absolutely critical
um but I would
and I have no problem like I I don't
want writers to think like they should
only write these genres and that they
should forever turn their back on any
passion project they have like their
passion is what got them into wanting to
do this in the first place they should
absolutely follow that at every step of
their career but what I'm saying is
utilize these core genres that do work
that are in need and apply what story
you want to tell within it like these
characters whether it's a tween girl
romance whether it's a female driven
Thriller whether it's a Christmas movie
like they even the creature features
like there are real stories and real
moments in there that are 100 purely
human interactions human conflict human
struggles uh and challenges that we can
all identify with
um you know there's a lot of kind of
stereotypical you would expect Sci-Fi
movies that actually have these very
powerful messages in them about how we
operate as as humans you can say that
about zombie movies what it really
reveals about who we are and I think
that they probably or a tween girl movie
what what it sort of tells about
whether you're male or female like what
what that feels like early in your life
when you're stumbling through this
transition of childhood to adulthood and
it's not just sex and puberty it's it's
all of the responsibilities that get
thrust on you and balancing how you grew
up versus what your personal experiences
of the world are and and all of that and
it's like you can funnel that into
something really fun and TV safe and
disney-esque and still be very you know
powerful in what you're trying to
communicate so I don't think that they
should dismiss it I think they should
utilize them
right let's let's say eighth grade did
you see that film I I didn't okay okay
so there were probably things that
wouldn't maybe be Advertiser friendly
for TV I loved it I know there was a
gentleman that walked out of the theater
when I was watching and I was surprised
but it sounds like for what you're
talking about is these are working
writers these are people that they
probably pay their rent pay their car
bill whatever through writing and if you
want to have a career you can you know
write the next precious which is amazing
but that's also very hard to get made
and so these are things that that are
consistent there's a there's a formula
to them and they work people people
watch them yeah and and I would add to
that like
if you want to have those moments of
being a staff writer on a series if you
want to have those moments of like that
passion project you want to see made you
need help to do it and you need a track
record to do it and you need
relationships to make that happen so
building a career showcasing you can do
the work you've done it consistently you
can be Dependable you deliver what you
say you're going to do time and time and
time again and you've showcased like my
stuff makes you money
um you're getting obviously paid for it
in exchange but like my stuff makes this
company money I'm delivering the goods
let's Elevate the relationship every
every person I know who's become a
director did it by working through the
ranks and proving they could do the work
before they actually got the job every
writer I've ever met proved they could
write before they got the job and if you
want to see your passion project made
you kind of have to showcase I get how
the industry works I'm totally in on it
I in terms of you know assisting and
playing my role and my part in making
that system operate and now it's my turn
to really put something forward and take
that first big leap you need help to do
it it's not I mean there's always
outliers I'm sure I'm sure you know
there's there's a couple of you know
pop-up titles sporadically here and
there that launched careers but for the
most part these overnight you know
success stories are like 10 15 years of
like hard dedicated work that finally
just crisscrossed into the big
opportunity
Boondock Saints yeah yeah that'd be one
of those stories and in truth that time
period that time era was very very
different and that was still when film
was the thing and theater was still what
it was and it wasn't being utilized
quite the same way it was today and uh
you know some of the personalities
picking that movie up or you know
they're they're how they are viewed in
history is very different in today's
world
um so a lot has changed since then and I
I don't I think it's really critical not
to hold yourself or judge yourself on
how other people built their careers or
what Milestones they hit and by what age
and when uh because you're gonna first
off you're gonna drive yourself nuts and
make yourself depressed and they were
operating in time periods and they had a
series of opportunities before them that
are just different you got to work with
the ones that are before you
but I think that if you want to get your
passion projects made
keep them going keep them in your back
pocket and it's important for Riders to
be able to like move from this project
to that project so that they're not
getting too involved and being able to
stay fresh on them uh but yeah if you
have that consistent work pattern and
you're getting regular deals you're not
selling out you're being professional
and you'll get those opportunities for
your own projects too sure and just as
distribution has changed and how we view
things sounds like how you get your
projects out there when you said you
read sidfield's screenplay excellent
advice and then the last chapter maybe
that's and I don't want to speak out of
school here but maybe it's outdated at
this point
in a sense like it goes back to
principles versus you know Trends and
all that like yeah I think the the
version of the book that I read like
suggested you still nail a hard copy
with a self-addressed stamped envelope
and all that stuff it's like our time is
just very different today but um the
concept of reaching out getting it in
front of people speaking learning how to
speak about your project
learning to speak with confidence which
is a skill in and of itself and it's one
that many people struggle with and it's
okay there's there's no shortage of
videos on YouTube to like learn how to
better present yourself but the truth is
you just got to get out there you got to
get your hands dirty you you got to get
your boots on the ground and and sort of
make the opportunities happen when
pitching should a writer speak 100 about
the story or should they also talk about
the business viability of the project I
think both I think
um
that's really at the end of the day what
it is it's it's a creative project that
answers a business problem and I think
screenwriters do need to view what
they're presenting as a business case in
addition to a story story is critical
and
um what happens in that story how it is
presented how it unfolds again even in
these like core genres that you think
are overly cliched it's like there's a
lot of story development and the number
of hours I've been on the phone or a
zoom talking about one project that's
just a A Christmas Story like it's it's
um it's quite intense uh but yeah it's
so story's critical but it being able to
answer the problems of the platform or
the network is also critical so when we
have those usually starts in this kind
of like process where it's first
I'm working with a writer and I'm
working with a network or VOD platform
separately I get the deal opportunity
closed then we get that script mapped
out written contracted Etc then we get
everybody in the room together and have
that big creative conversation and uh
yeah during that process it's we're
pitching the script but we're also
pitching it as a business case and why
it's going to make that company money or
why it's going to bring in audience or
what things does it need to have in it
that are going to help them grow their
grow their company grow Their audience
base or you know increase revenues and
when you're on a phone call back and
forth about a project for many months is
it is it story driven that you're that
you're discuss is it story based that
you're discussing issues or is it
location all the above it's all of the
above I mean story you know is the big
filter It's gotta work the theme has to
work uh the character has to follow the
right Journey
um but how that happens yeah we we do
dive a lot into the
the tangible uh uh I guess technicality
of how are we actually going to execute
this thing because it's not just words
on the paper you're going to have to
have a crew behind the camera so if that
conversation is taking place in a car
while it's driving why like just
put it on a bench you know put it
someplace that's easy to shoot
um uh the number of characters and
there's you know I just had a
conversation with a writer um
a few days ago and she was very specific
about wanting a character in a scene
with no dialogue because story-wise she
felt it was very important and I'm sort
of in this situation of sort of
explaining yeah but we got to pay all
this extra money for them to be on set
for that one day and they may not need
to be there and it does there is a kind
of a balance in terms of like cost
economics Commerce versus the creative
storytelling budgets are tight on a lot
of Productions and so you have to
balance that so it's it's a big hybrid
and it's usually you're talking both at
the same time on specific points
but story opens the door
and I would say the the um the details
of the execution the business case are
what close the deal